smartphone cameras allow us to capture
the world around us
but by definition they're always in the
way
that's my snapchat made these spectacles
they're 130 dollars sunglasses with a
video camera that records 10 seconds
which means I'm going to be cut off
right about now guess i'll have to speak
faster anyway you press this button up
here and then action look no hands this
ring of LEDs tells people that you're
recording hi mom
hi I need a tissue then you grab your
smartphone open snapchat and it
transfers the files in way longer than
10 seconds then you can review the save
files and post them on snapchat the
videos are circular so you can watch
them vertically or horizontally on your
phone that's pretty cool the quality
great terrible the technology inside
these are dead simple but the rules of
wearing a camera aren't so I'm sending
some spectacles do's and don'ts do
record fun experiences like ice skating
oh no I'm going the wrong way why did I
choose ice skating do you record special
face-to-face interactions they're
awesome when trying to capture kids or
pets push it ok do you give me
permission to record you yeah yeah do
record unique places and things the
first-person point of view is amazing
don't be that person and record people
without their permission no no your soup
looks good seriously if you're capturing
people's faces just tell them you're
recording ok so you're recording me now
right now recording I have a how am I
wearing sunglasses inside and don't
record everything so what do you guys
think of my lunch the love of everyone's
privacy don't record in bathrooms locker
rooms or any private or restricted areas
and for the love of all your followers
don't record in the shower ultimately
just because you're wearing
weird-looking sunglasses that conceal a
camera doesn't mean you should stop
respecting people's or pets privacy is
it ok if I record this that's enough
that's enough you're gonna steal my job